Musik
Rhein, wir haben halt so ein bisschen so ein Wetten-Das-Setup. Wir haben so eine gekrümmte Couch mit so verschiedenen Couch-Elementen, auf der wir heute locker sitzen. Aber du siehst nicht glücklich aus. Du hättest dich nicht gut gemacht. Sorry, dass ich gerade so ein bisschen Gedanken verloren bin. Ich habe gerade eine ganz interessante Spam-Mail bekommen. Und ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn Spam-Mails gut sind, klicke ich auch gerne auf den Link, der da drin ist. Oder ich versuche dann gerne mal die Bitcoin zu gewinnen. Weil ich denke mir, das sind die 1% aller Spam-Mail-Autoren, die sich Mühe geben. Und es steht hier, Hello, gute Frage, komplett nutzlose Antwort.net-Team, my name is Asia. Moment, was? My name is Asia, I'm a co-founder of Riverteam. Und die worked with fashion influencers. Aber wie, gute Frage, komplett nutzlose Antwort.de. Ich glaube, ich habe mich gut angefragt für ... Das ist keine Spam, sondern ich habe mich gut angefragt als Influencer.
Hä, das habe ich doch mal gemacht, den Gag als Tweet.
Gute Frage, komplettnutzloseantwort.de.
Ja, das ist der Gag, mit dem sie, mit dem Asia ...
Kein guter Name.
Mit dem Asia vom Riverteam einsteigt.
Hä, einfach so?
Einfach so als Gag, glaube ich.
Ey, wenn Bots jetzt Gags machen, haben wir ein fucking Problem. Ist dir schon klar, Stefan? Ja, ich sagte das, aber die fangen doch schon an. Also Maschinenhumor. Der erste Name, wir wollten ja Gute Arbeit erst ganz anders nennen. Wir wollten es erst nennen Ostrich Wars. Ja, ist richtig. Die Straußenkriege. Auch ein Gag von einem Bot. Ja. Und sind wir mal ehrlich, diesen Gag hätten weder du noch ich jemals geschrieben. Da fehlen uns die Eier, da fehlen uns die Cojones, und da fehlt uns aber auch der Intellekt und die Smartness. Ja, es gab so einen Bot, der irgendwie so willkürliche Worte getwittert hat, und darunter war auch Ostrich Wars. Und wir dachten uns, was weiß er, dass wir nicht wissen, was waren das für Straussenkriege? Und Funfact, es gab Straussenkriege. Richtig, es gab, ich glaube, eine Armee von 20 Straussen gegen die Armee von Australien und die Straussen haben gewonnen. Ja, Straussen gegen, und das Lustige ist, dann hast du tatsächlich ja immer bei What the fuck, was das denn? Der Tisch, sorry. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Aber es gibt ja bei, und es gibt ja nichts Besseres als Schlachtseiten von Wikipedia. Ah, Traum. Du hast nämlich dann Recht, diese Aufstellung, wer gegen wen, welche Anführer es gab, welche Mannesstärke und wie die ineinander gelaufen sind. Und auch bei den Austrich Wars hattest du dann Straussarmee gegen Australien. Ungleicher Kampf. Und dann hast du links Anführer bei Straussen, Strich, Anführer bei dann irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, Mr. Smith, und dann Mannestärke irgendwie 56 Straussen, glaube ich, gegen 180 Australier.
Es gibt auch eine Wikipedia-Schlachtseite von einem Kampf zwischen Affen. Und zwar, soweit ich weiss, haben da Forscher zwei Affenstämme beobachtet. Und ich glaube, zwei Forscherteams haben zwei verschiedene Affenstämme beobachtet und die haben irgendwann miteinander gekämpft und die hatten denen halt alle Namen gegeben und hatten die Hierarchie verstanden und so, wer ist der Anführer? Und dann haben die halt einfach aus Scheiß und die Wikipedia-Seite angelegt, Kampf zwischen Affen und also acht Affen gegen drei Affen und dann haben zwei Affen wurden getötet und dann irgendwie so Resultat Sieg der blauen Gruppe oder so. Ich weiss nicht mehr genau, wie der hies, der Edikamp, ich habe leider kein Internet hier, wie immer, aber an sich sehr interessant.
Aids! Man muss sagen, das Podcast-Ufo sagt jetzt Aids dem Kampf an. Wir springen da auf den Pfahlentzug, also ich glaube... So, jetzt hol mal aus, Frau Eichhörn. So, viele Leute... Hallo erstmal,llo auch. Hallo erstmal, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo, das sind Florentin Will, das sind Stefan Tietze. Und das Podcast-Ufo trägt ab jetzt diese Aids-Schleife, diese rote. Das hatten wir schon im Logo gesehen. Das muss er jetzt einbauen im Logo. Nein, nicht. Nee, das veränderst du. Das schießt den ganzen Feed, das ist mega scheiße. Oh, wenn der Shutterstock drauf ist. Scheiß auf Aids, scheiß auf Aids Ist er schießt den Feed? Naja, passt auf, es ist Wahnsinn, wofür das Podcast-Ufer wird Menschenleben retten. Und zwar kriege ich diese ganz, ganz tolle Mail von Torben Pelzer. Und der ist nämlich von der Uni Leipzig. Und der schreibt mir folgende Mail, super nett. Lieber Stefan, deine HIV-Resistenz durch die CCR5-Delta-32-Mutation ist sehr selten.
Vielleicht ein Prozent. Es war also kein Scheiß. Diese Mutation gibt es wirklich. Du hast deine Gene analysieren lassen und hast dabei herausgefunden, durch einen illegalen Drittanbieter hast du noch deine Krankheitswahrscheinlichkeit rausgefunden. Ich habe herausgefunden von einer Mutation, die ich haben soll. Ja, und jetzt kommt raus, ich bin tatsächlich, jetzt haben wir uns letzte Woche gefragt, was denn genau Resistenz heißt. Es heißt aber tatsächlich, ich bin verdammt noch mal immun. Resistenz ist dasselbe Immunität. Gegen HIV-1. Und das ist die weit verbreitetste HIV-Krankheit, Infektion, heißt also, ich bin immun gegen Aids. Meiner Meinung nach ja immer noch der beste Aids. Aids 1 für mich ungeschlagen. Die Top 3 Aids-Sorten. Auf Platz 3, bei mir HIV 3 tatsächlich. Bei mir HIV B. Oh, auf Platz 2, bei mir HIV 2. Bei mir auf Platz 2 den Aids, den nur Eichhörnchen bekommen können. Oh, und auf Platz eins natürlich HIV-1. Natürlich bei mir auch HIV-1. Selbstverständlich. Und jetzt, ich kann es nicht fassen, ich gehöre zu einem Prozent der Menschheit, die immun gegen HIV-1 sind. Und er schreibt, dass ich von meiner Motivation weiß, ist sogar noch ein grösserer Zufall. Weil klar, die meisten wissen halt nicht, dass sie diese CCR5 Delta 32 Mutationen halt in sich tragen.
Es ist nämlich ein Protein, das irgendwie bei
meinem Blut nicht existiert, und das ist
das Protein, wo sich der AIDS-Virus andockt.
Und das Protein habe ich
eigentlich nicht, ich weiß nicht, was ich dadurch für Schwächen
habe, dann auf der anderen Seite, weil wir haben herausgefunden,
letztes Woche ja auch, dass immer wenn man
was Gutes bekommt, ein Plus,
dann kriegst du auch ein Minus. Richtig, die Welt ist fair. Richtig, weil Gott dich erstellt an seinem Sims-Modulator. Aber Stefan Tietze, du kennst das Sprichwort, aus großem Zufall folgt grosse Verantwortung. Du bist Resistenz gegen Aids, also was machst du da aus? So, und jetzt hat er gesagt, die erste belegte Heilung eines HIV-Patienten, der berühmte Berlin-Patient, der erkennt ihn nicht, den Berlin-Patient, falls du es nachlesen möchtest, hat er mit linken Schicht, erfolgte, indem er eine Knochenmarkspende einer Person erhielt, die eine solche Mutation besitzt. Ich sollte also unbedingt überlegen, Knochenmarkspender zu werden, denn das konnte vielen Menschen helfen. Es grüsst, und jetzt hat er geschrieben, was seine Vorteile sind, er erinnert mich diese Mutation nicht, es grüssten vier Prozent Neandertaler mit einer siebenfachen Wahrscheinlichkeit für kompletten Haarausfall, der genetisch bedingt niesen muss, wenn er in die Sonne guckt.
Jackpot. Tja, naja. Es sind nicht alle Menschen genetisch gleich, Stefan. Es sind nicht alle gegen HIV immun. Naja, und jetzt habe ich überlegt, ich habe mir schon so einen Termin gemacht bei meinem Hausarzt, ich werde auf jeden Fall Knochenmarkspender, Aber Sekunde. Ich will mich in die Kartei aufnehmen lassen.
Und wahrscheinlich liege ich dann bei meinen guten Genen jede Woche unter dem Messer und
muss irgendwelchen Aids-Kranken meine Stammzellen geben. Die wollen nicht ausschlachten. Jetzt werde ich ausgenutzt. Aber heißt das dann, die Person, der du Rückenmark gibst, ist dann auch immun gegen Aids, oder warum ist das jetzt besonders? Oder was hat dein Rückenmark? Aber das heißt jetzt wirklich, wenn du... Ich weiß, das will ich nicht, nicht ich habe keine ahnung aber kannst du jetzt nicht so eine art aids jäger werden weil wenn du jetzt geschlechtsverkehr mit jemandem hast der aids hat ich glaube dass der dann automatisch das nicht aber das überträgt sich nicht aber dann kannst du zum aids jäger werden weil es gibt ja leute die aktiv aids verbreiten ist ja die beste der beste mord ach so verstehehe. Und ich kann die entlarven. Warum? Naja, du kannst ja so... Weil die sagen nachher, haha, du hast Aids. Und dann sage ich, nein, ich bin immun. Ich gotcha. Dann hole ich meine Aids-Jäger-Marke raus und sage, und er sagt, nein, der Aids-Jäger. Stefan Tietze Aids-Jäger? Wenn ich drei Staffeln würde, würde ich mir das anschauen. Stefan Tietze Aids-Jäger. Aids-Stefan, das ist jetzt ... Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hätte ich noch mal drüber nachdenken sollen im Kopf, aber Aids-Stefan finde ich schon nicht so schlecht. Du warst eine Woche lang Stefan-Woke-Titze, bevor du eine neue Form angenommen hast. Stefan-Aids-Titze. Stefan-Aids-Titze geht jetzt auf Aids-Jagd. Welche Formen hat das jetzt? Wir sagen Aids den Kampf an, und jetzt wird Aids ausgerottet und ich schmeiße meine Stammzellen in den Club und schreie Hey und dann wird der Aids ausgemerzt. Aber das heißt doch jetzt, also ich meine Evolution ist ja Mutation, Selektion, gute Mutation soll sich verbreiten. Ja, das Thema hatten wir schon mal. Das heißt, eigentlich musst du jetzt dafür sorgen, dass deine positive, gute Mutation sich möglichst oft verbreitet. Das heißt, ich würde sagen, jetzt wird gebumst, bis der Arzt kommt. Jetzt wird gebumst, erst mal Stefan Bumst-Hitze. Jetzt musst du loslegen. Der Aids-Hitze hat man so. Tatsächlich habe ich jetzt auch die ersten Verwandten in den USA geschrieben über die Seite. Also es hört nicht auf, Spaß zu machen. Haben die geschrieben? Ich habe die angeschrieben. Die hast du angeschrieben. Und die heißen Rosinski mit Nachnamen. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass meine Oma, die ich nie kennengelernt habe, Eltern hatten, die bei ihrer Hochzeit, also meine Urgroßeltern, haben bei der Hochzeit den Namen Rosinski in Rosna geändert. Heisst also, die 25 Prozent Polens waren aber damals Preussen haben tatsächlich Sinn ergeben.
Es war heut Prozent Polen, das waren aber damals Preussen,
haben tatsächlich Sinn ergeben. Es war heutiges
Polen,
damaliges Preussen, also
die 25 Prozent Polen stimmen also daher
offensichtlich und die
hießen Rosinski und ich habe mit einer Angel Rosinski
in den USA geschrieben,
die in Milwaukee wohnt,
was total interessant ist. Milwaukee!
Ja, Milwaukee. Da ist Red Letter Media. Wirklich? Ja, ohne Scheiß. Ja, und die machen nächsten Monat eine Family Reunion. Wollen wir nicht einfach in der Milwaukee? Aber ohne Scheiß, da gehen wir sofort hin. Dann schauen wir mal bei denen vorbei und nehmen mit denen ein Video auf. Ja, finde ich so schlecht. Milwaukee, große Family Reunion. Und dann kannst du ja nebenbei mal so droppen, dass du keinen Aids kriegen kannst. Ja, als frischgebackener Aids-Rosinski, Stefan Aids-Rosinski, was mein neuer Name ist.
Ja, fahren fliegen wir hin, finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber ist das eine gute Anmach-Pick-Up-Line, wo du sagst, so pass auf, unsere Kinder wären vielleicht Aids-immun? Ein Hörer hat mich schon geschrieben, wäre gut fürs Tinder-Profil auf jeden Fall. Ja. Ich kann keinen Aids bekommen. Gibt ja bei manchen Dating-Plattformen, muss man ja sagen, wenn man das letzte Mal sich getestet hat gegen Geschlechtskrankheiten, da habe ich auch einfach vor, dann immer einzutragen. Ne, habe ich noch nicht, bin aber Aids-immun. Resistent. Ich finde, immun klingt besser. Ach, ich finde das nicht schlecht. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die ein Prozent, die das haben, natürlich von denen, wie viele wissen das dann von denen? Nochmal ein Prozent. Also wirklich ein Bruchteil aller Menschen kann von sich das sagen. Haie sind auch Aids immun, nee, Krebs immun, Haie sind Krebs immun. Angenommen du und ein Hai. Warum sind die Krebs immun? Sind sie einfach. Warum haben wir denn nicht überall Hai-Stammzellen? Angenommen, hi und du. Ihr könntet den besten Menschen der Welt gebären. Immun gegen Aids,
Immun gegen Krebs, kann super schnell schwimmen, ist super lustig. Der beste Mensch. Mit ein Delfin dann. Wusstest du übrigens, es kam in der Film raus, The Shape of Water, wo es ja primär darum geht, dass eine Frau sich in ein Tier verliebt. Und mit dem dann eine... Ja, in ein humanoides Fischwesen. Okay, ein humanoides Fischwesen. Und dann quasi auch eine sexuelle Beziehung mit dem eingeht. Und dann hat tatsächlich ein Mann darauf gewartet, so ein bisschen, sein Leben lang offensichtlich, der mal Sex mit einem Delfin hatte. Ja, ein perfektes Timing. Ein berühmter Zoophila-Mann, der Sex mit einem Delfin hatte, hat sich dann zu Wort gemeldet und hat gesagt, ja, ihr mögt diesen Film alle, und mich habt ihr damals fertig gemacht. Es war doch auch und alle so, Jesus, komm runter, Alter, das ist nicht zu vergleichen. Das ist nicht zu vergleichen, okay, okay, und ist er wieder ins Wasser gegangen. Aber der hat wirklich, und da gibt es so eine Doku bei YouTube, die sehr verstörend ist, der hat wirklich einfach Sex, richtig Sex mit den Delfinen gehabt. Aber mit dem Luftloch dann, oder was? Nee, nee, nee, er hat wirklich seinen Penis in die Vagina des Delfins gesteckt. Sie wollte es, hat er gesagt, Victim Blaming. Ist man da nicht unter Wasser? Wie geht das? Ja, unter Wasser. Aber es war halt so ein Delfinarium wohl und dann gab es... Ein was? Ein D Also ein Ort, wo nur... Das macht mich auch ein bisschen aneinander. Ziemlich ruhig ein bisschen... Oh, ist auch nicht warm geworden hier drin, oder? Und dann kam diese, muss man sagen, heiße Delfinin kam dann an, immer zu ihm ans Ufer und dann war er schon ein bisschen flacher, dass er stehen konnte da durchaus und sich hat auch immer an ihm gerieben, hat er gesagt. Und dann irgendwann kam halt eins zum anderen. Und dann war die Badehose weg und sie hat ihren heißen Delfinrock ausgezogen. Und dann, es ist wirklich ganz, ganz schrecklich. Es ist wirklich total explizit beschrieben. Und der Typ hat dann gesagt, als Shape of Water rauskam, Oh, Leute! Ja. Meine Geschichte. Es muss so viele Leute geben, die irgendwelche weirden Fetische haben, die nur auf diesen einen Film warten, wo jemand mit einer Leiche Sex hat und plötzlich so, da habt ihr es doch. Bradley Cooper ist cool, wenn er es macht und ich bin pervers. Der Kannibale von Rotenburg ist okay, wenn er Menschen ist, oder? Ja, du bist der Kannibale von Rotenburg, der Film ist über dich. Dieser arme Berlin-Patient, stell dir vor, du wirst von Aids geheilt. Ja, Herr Ufnowski, das ist ein legendärer, geschichtsträchtiger Fall, Sie sind der erste Mensch, dem Aids geheilt war. Sie werden in die Geschichte eingehen. Heißt das jetzt der berühmte Ufnowski-Fall? Wir haben uns jetzt geeinigt auf Berlin-Patienten. Jesus Christ! Weil sie in Berlin wohnen. Wie Berlin-Patient? Weil sie in Berlin wohnen. Ufnowski! Der berühmte Fall Ufnowski. Ja. Nicht so catchy, oder? Wir haben jetzt schon Berlin geschrieben. Uffi! Meine Freundin, nämlich Uffi! Nee. Nee, tut mir leid. Bist du auch Aids-resistent? Nee. Ich weiß es nicht, ich musste mich testen lassen. Bis jetzt habe ich noch keinen... Vielleicht hatte ich schon Kontakt mit Aids, ich weiß es nicht. Weiss man nicht, ne? Vielleicht. Ich kannte mal jemanden, der kurz Angst hatte. Also ein schwuler Freund von mir, der hat mal Angst gehabt, Aids zu haben, weil dann irgendwann kam ein Anruf, ein ganz aufgelöster Anruf von einem ehemaligen Sexualpartner, der gesagt hat, ich habe jetzt rausgefunden, dass ich Aids habe. Tschschüss, und dann ist es natürlich erst mal furchtbar. Und dann hat er gesagt, er wusste, dass er das nicht hat, weil man würde ja merken, wenn es einem schlecht geht. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja. Unschlagbare Logik. Mega Logik. Du hast wahrscheinlich keinen Aids, und dann hat er auch keinen Aids. Weißt du, manchmal, du hast manchmal so Tage an, den wachst du auf und denkst dir, weißt du was, mir mag es schlecht gehen, ich habe keinen Aids. Ich spüre das, ich habe keinen fucking Aids. Man spürt es. Man spürt es. Ich meine, so eine Lampe hätte aber gut. So eine Lampe. Man würde es spüren. Ja, ich glaube, das ist die eine Sache, die man spürt, wenn man Aids hat oder nicht. aber unangenehmer Anruf, oder? Also angenommen, du findest raus, du hast Aids und dann musst du irgendwie die
alle...
sagen wir jetzt mal...
also... Aber unangenehmer Anruf, oder? Also angenommen, du findest raus, du hast Aids und dann musst du irgendwie die alle, sagen wir jetzt mal, also die alle, also du musst dir alle, alle Menschen und also du musst Rosi die Delphine nochmal anrufen und sagen, übrigens. Was ist, wenn jemand stirbt? Ich überlege mir mal, wen ruft man alles an, wenn jemand stirbt? Wie, wenn du stirbst? Also angenommen, ein Freund von mir stirbt, soll ich dann zum Beispiel so etwas wie die Exfreundin von dem anrufen? Erst mal, warum solltest du derjenige sein, der diese Anrufe macht? Naja, weil ich halt in dem Freundeskreis bin. Oder sollen die Eltern sich darum kümmern? Die Eltern haben sich darum zu kümmern. Aber die kennen ja den Freundeskreis nicht so gut. Dann werden die den engsten Freund anrufen und sagen, kannst du dich um die Einladungen für die Beerdigung kümmern? Derjenigen, mit dem er... Aber wie weit geht das? Bis wo geht die Grenze? Interessant ist, dass je jünger der Verstorbene oft, also Schüler haben ja oft Beerdigungen, die sind riesig, die sind da, ist ja fast immer die ganze Schule da, und je älter du wirst, desto weniger Leute kommen auf deine Beerdigung. Das heißt, wenn du eine richtig geile Beerdigung haben willst, wo richtig die Tränen fliessen, also wo richtig wirklich Armageddon ist, dann musst du relativ früh dir vornehmen zu sterben. Außer du bist Sting. Dann hast du die Best-Bedding, außer du bist Sting.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Dann kommen eine Menge Leute.
Das stimmt.
Als Sting-Aids?
Könnte ich Sting heilen?
Schwer zu sagen.
Wen könnte ich heilen?
Ich hätte Freddie Mercury heilen können.
Aber kannst du heilen?
Die müssen meine Stammzellen.
Vor allem Stammzelle, ich glaube, da muss ich
unter Vollnarkose operiert werden. Das müssen wir unter Vollnarkose, weil das sehr schmerzhaft ist sonst, entnommen werden. Und ich habe jetzt Angst, wenn ich jetzt so ein seltener Fall bin, dass sie mich jede Woche anrufen und sagen, wer hat denn wieder einen? Ja, stimmt, da kommst du nicht mehr raus. Und dann kennen die mich auch schon so mit Vornamen, da muss ich wieder dahin. Und dann muss ich mal fragen, habe ich schon genug Blut wieder in meinem Körper, dass ihr mir das entnehmen könnt? Du wirst einfach so angeschlossen wie in der Matrix einfach so, dir wird immer was entnommen einfach. Aber es gab mal eigentlich mal, das hat mir auch ein Arbeitskollege erzählt, es gab mal diesen einen Menschen mit einer sehr seltenen Blutgruppe. Und dann gab es irgendwie in Australien Babys, die geboren wurden mit einem Fehler, mit irgendeinem Virus oder irgendeinem körperlichen Fehler.
Und diese Blutgruppe haben die rausgefunden, konnte das heilen.
Es gab auch nur diesen einen Menschen und der hat dann zwei Millionen Babys das Leben gehalten in Australien.
Und er ist sowas wie ein Nationalheld.
Das ist schon krass.
Also es ist mein Ziel, allen Menschen auf der Welt zu helfen, Aids loszuwerden.
So eine Art Anti-Vampir, der anderen Leuten sein Blut gibt.
Ich finde, Gefallen an Stefan-Aids-Tieze.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Aber du hast eine Menge Verantwortung.
Wie Verantwortung?
Naja, du musst dich jetzt drum kümmern.
Hör auf, immer hier mit Blechen zu werfen.
Wenn du jetzt einfach sagst, ich gehe zwei Wochen nach Costa Rica,
dann sagen die Leute, ja, aber ich habe Aids.
Ciao!
Ich habe immer noch Aids!
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin echt ein bisschen schlecht drauf.
Warum bist du schlecht drauf? Du erwischt mich an einem schlechten Punkt.
Was ist denn los?
Es ist so total dumm, aber ich habe gerade total dummen Warcraft-Spiel verloren.
Wirklich jetzt?
Ja, und es macht mich fertig. Es ist so scheiße einfach. Es gibt so zwei Arten... Niederlage. Die, wo du keinen Bock mehr hast. Nee, Warcraft 3, das Strategiespiel. Aber die World of Warcraft ist die Welt des Warcrafts. Richtig, ja. Aber die gleiche Welt. Ja, es gibt auch ein anderes Spiel, aber es ist die gleiche Welt. Es gibt so zwei Arten von Niederlagen, wo du sagst, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, und die, wo du danach noch mehr Bock hast.
Und ich verstehe noch nicht genau, wann welche bei mir ist. Ich habe es noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Ich glaube, in Singlespieler, wenn ich dann irgendwie an einem Boss sterbe, habe ich direkt gar keinen Bock mehr und hör auf.
Aber wenn ich gegen echte Menschen spiele, habe ich noch mehr Lust, den Nächsten fertig zu machen.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, ich habe nicht so viel Erfahrung im Verlieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Aids-Tize mag. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Wie viel Prozent Arschloch hattest du deinen Genrechnen? 99 Prozent Arschloch. 1 Prozent Aids-Revizit. Ich habe auch die Erfahrung gemacht, bei FIFA tatsächlich, online FIFA zu spielen. Am Anfang betritt man so eine neue Welt. Vor allem, wenn man sich dann irgendwann, ich habe mir mal dieses Bluttooth-Headset gekauft. Bluttooth? Bluttooth-Headset. Ist das der Kopf oder für Vampire, oder was? Ja, das steht auch dafür. Bluttooth. Und erst denkt man, ja, ich spiele einfach online, so wieder entspannt sein und mache bestimmt Spaß. Tatsächlich wird man die meiste Zeit beschimpft. Auf sehr diversen Sprachen wird man einfach angeschissen. Und erst ist das total verstörend. Man versteht einfach nicht, warum das gerade passiert. Aber nach drei Niederlagen bist du derjenige, der den anderen anscheißt. Weil irgendwann kannst du nicht mehr. Die Wut muss ja auch irgendwo hin. Vor allem, du wirst auf Russisch beschimpft. Das ist bei Dota sehr oft. Du wirst beschimpft in einer Sprache, die du nicht verstehst. Und das ist, weil du denkst dir, wenn ich beschimpft werde, dann will ich auch grob verstehen, was jetzt genau beschimpft wird. Ich hätte gerne eine Chance für einen Konter. Ja, ich konnte in der Regel nicht, aber es ist dann so, vor allem da ist dann ein Russe mit vier Europäern in einem Team und er flamet die ganze Zeit. Da denkst du dir so, warum tust du das? Also wenn man nicht mal weiss, dass es nicht mal ankommt, was man schreibt, sondern die
schreiben dann nur ihre Phantasiezeichen, ihre Kreuzvertretelzeichen dann so. Und man denkt sich so, was wird das? Also ich würde es zumindest verstehen wollen. Die haben ja schon im Prinzip, das ist ja nicht wie die Chinesen mit dem neuen Alphabet, also wo man keine Chance hat, das zu übersetzen. Also deren Alphabet ist ja, die haben einfach nur andere, die haben einfach alles mal getauscht. Ja, die haben eine I statt eine U. Das A ist ein B, das I ist ein U. Die haben einfach einmal durchgewürfelt. Das Ö ist ein N. Das einfach mal durch. Da kommt die Sprache nur durch Beleidigung lernen. Ich glaube, da kriegt man viel mit. Ich glaube, auf Deutsch hast du da auch einen schwierigen Stand, weil die ganzen deutschen Schimpfwörter wie Arschloch und Scheisse sind, glaube ich, relativ verbreitet. Ey, Ich habe mir letztens mal nachgedacht, wie fucking schwer Deutsch ist. Deutsch ist so schwer. Es ist wirklich schwer. Ja. Weil vor allem manchmal ähneln sich grammatikalische Sachen, also zum Beispiel das Auto gehört der Frau. Das checkt doch kein Mensch. Warum es jetzt der heißt, wo es heißt doch die Frau, der Mann, aber das Auto gehört der Frau. Vor allem hat mich noch einmal ein Amerikaner gefragt, wenn ich jetzt zu dir sage, kochst du selber? Wie sage ich das denn zu einer Frau? Ja. Und ich so, das Gleiche, kochst du selber? Und er, wieso denn? Dieselbe. Kochst du selbe? Ja. Aber nein. Und natürlich ist es absurd, dass es nicht so ist, dass du das nicht angleichst. Die Sprache ist natürlich schon noch ein bisschen männlich, dann muss man schon sagen. Es ist so hart. Und das fällt einem ja gar nicht auf, wenn man das spricht, aber genau wie die oft erwähnten Abtönungspartikel wie Halt oder Ja im Satz, das ist halt so, kannst du nicht übersetzen. Du kannst niemandem erklären, was dieses Halt soll oder so ein Ja. Ich kann dir ja immer was geben. Versteht auch niemand, was es im Satz soll. Das ist so eine super deutsche Sache. Vor allem ist es so schwer, weil es einerseits so kompliziert ist, aber so faul, dass es sich immer wieder, also zum Beispiel jetzt, ich liebe den Mann, hast du mit denen ein eigenes Wort, aber ich liebe die Frau. Es wird ja gar nichts. Und dann musst du lernen, nicht nur musst du lernen, dass es bei manchen Fällen manche Artikel verändert werden, sondern auch noch in welchen Neues. Es ist so schwer. Ich bin echt froh, dass ich kein Deutsch lernen muss. Ja, aber muss man ja auch nicht. Eigentlich nicht, oder? Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man nicht, warum sagen man nicht immer alle Schulen einfach gleichzeitig auf allen Ländern der Welt und jetzt wird nur noch Englisch beigebracht. Ja. Nur noch. Es würde so viele Probleme lösen. Oder mal den Dativ raus. So, komm einfach ein Fall weg. Den Dativ raus? Weg mit dem Dativ. Wie so denn? Genitiv. Nee. Genitiv, Proll-Genitiv, sag ich. Genitiv ist super wichtig, Dativ. Warum ist Genitiv wichtig? Ja, so, Eigentum. Die meisten ist wichtig. Aber da kann Dativ doch auch noch schlucken. Dein Fahrrad, mein Fahrrad, aber wehmenst Fahrrad scheiß drauf. Das interessiert mich nicht. Ne, so funktioniert das nicht, mit Fellen streichen. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Ich habe mein Fahrrad, easy. Ich bin aber auch froh, dass ich... Wem kaufe ich das? Scheiß drauf, ich hab das jetzt. Ich bin froh, als Deutscher mit Deutsch groß geworden zu sein. Ich bin aber auch froh, mit dem Eurovision Song-Contest groß geworden zu sein, weil den kannst du auch nicht erklären.
Und den verstehst du auch nicht, wenn du Amerikaner bist.
Der gleiche Amerikaner hat mich gefragt,
was ist dieses große Ereignis, von dem alle sprechen
am Samstag, und ich so,
also naja, ist ein bisschen wie Hunger Games,
also jeder schickt dann seinen
Kandidaten dahin,
und dann hoffen alle, dass die gewinnen,
aber, und dann meinte er,
die meisten Songs sind ja nicht gut,
und dann erklär den Leuten mal,
dass Montenegro jedes Jahr
Aber Und dann hoffen alle, dass die gewinnen. Aber, und dann meinte er, ja, die meisten Songs sind ja nicht gut. Und dann erklär den Leuten mal, dass Montenegro jedes Jahr versucht, den Eurovision Song Contest zu trollen mit irgendeinem seltsamen crappy Beitrag, weil die nicht gewinnen wollen. Erklär das mal Leuten, dass die meisten Länder nicht gewinnen wollen, weil die den Eurovision Song Contest wollen zwar teilnehmen. Weil die müssen auch zahlen, um teilz, ne? Ja, aber die müssen noch mehr zahlen, wenn sie den ausrichten wollen. Und es schluckt teilweise so das doppelte Bruttoinlandsprodukt von Montenegro, wenn das nächstes Jahr in Montenegro wäre. Und je schlechter sie sind, desto gering ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es bei denen ist, oder wie? Ja, also trollen die jedes Jahr. Also das ist so, wie wenn man sagt, ah, kannst du mal abspülen, und dann spült man bewusst ganz schlecht ab, damit man nie wieder gefragt wird. Richtig. Ja, du hast durchschaut, wie Montenegro jedes Jahr funktioniert. Das Problem ist, dass man nicht, dass Finnland zum Beispiel mit Lordi so gut getrollt hat, dass sie gewonnen haben. Und dann fangen wiederum an, die guten Länder zu trollen und schicken seltsame Beiträge dahin. Und dann wird das alles noch Wirrwarr und dann kommt wieder Urban dazu und dann versteht man gar nichts mehr und dann ist auch der Eurovision Song jetzt geboren. Und das habe ich nicht erklärt bekommen. Ich bin froh, dass man damit irgendwie sozialisiert wurde. Weil es ist einfach eine fantastische Veranstaltung. Ich finde richtig Spaß. Ich finde das so eine lustige Vorstellung, du mit diesem Amerikaner im Gespräch. Und was war 1940? Ja. Also es war dann so, Montenegro kam mit diesem Affen. War frech. Montenegro war einfach frech. Und dann gibt es noch ein paar Regeln, nur sechs Leute auf der Bühne, Kinder verboten und Tiere verboten. Aber was ist ein Tier, was ist dieses Fischmonster? Ich würde vor allem gerne die Geschichte hinter dem Verbot wissen. Warum sind die Mewerschen dann gesagt, war da mal irgendwann ein Tier auf der Bühne und dann haben die Leute gesagt, so, alles klar, danke, mehr der Versuch. Es hat abgeräumt. Jetzt ist es, wir die Regel auf. Ja, ich glaube, es gibt einfach, es wurde alles schon mal probiert, genauso wie, dass du zu einem Schachturnier einfach irgendwie so einen Huhn anmeldest. Und dann irgendwie Hunowitsch. Und dann sagen die, kannst du jetzt nicht mit einem Huhn kommen? Und dann setzen die das Huhn aufs Schachbrett und dann sagen alle, das ist ja lächerlich. Das hat Montenegro schon vor drei Jahren gemacht. Und dann sagen die, okay, müssen wir jetzt extra wegen dir Depp reinschreiben, dass kein Huhn teilnehmen kann.
Das ist genau wie dieser Rose, nee, nicht, wie heißt der, der Basketballspielende Hund?
Erbard.
Dank.
Wo anscheinend, also in dem Film war es so, in den Regeln steht nirgendwo, dass ein Hund nicht mitspielen darf.
Wuff, wuff, und dann drückt er den Ball in den Korb.
Wirklich?
Ja, ob das wirklich so ist, weiß ich nicht. Ist das die Prämisse des Films oder die Lösung des Films, das Finale des Films?
Sowohl als auch.
Es sind so zwei Filme in einem so ein bisschen.
Der eine Film hört auf und dann wird es schwarz und dann geht es immer von vorne an. Es ist merkwürdig, es ist ein komischer Film einfach.
Aber da habe ich mal gemerkt, wie weird das ist. Und dann macht er Australien mit, dann erklär man Leuten, dass alle Länder aus Europa mitmachen und Russland und Albanien und überhaupt ganz Westasien und Australien.
Naja, das war ein bisschen weird. Es ist manchmal nicht einfach, Dinge zu erklären,
die man für gegeben nimmt,
weil man damit groß geworden ist.
Man kann Australien jetzt auch nicht rausschmeißen.
Man hat die, glaube ich, zu einem 40-jährigen Jubiläum,
nee, 50-jährigen Jubiläum oder so,
da hat man die eingeladen,
und seitdem sind die da.
Das ist wie so ein unangenehmer Freund,
den man zur Party eingeladen hat,
weil man den noch getroffen hat vor dem Supermarkt, und dann ist der letzte Gast. Aber warum habt ihr so viel Bier gekauft? Ja, und du kannst nicht sagen, nächstes Jahr laden wir den einfach nicht ein, weil er weiß, wann die Party ist. Und dann so, hier bin ich. Und man muss auch sagen, man hat auch schon, auch mit dem man auch nicht so eng ist, Albanien, Montenegro auch eingeladen. Ja, aber die will man nicht ausladen, die machen die fertig. Und man lacht Australien auch ganz gern, mal ehrlich gesagt. Du, ich hab nichts gegen Australien. Australien ist auch ein cooler Typ, der auch ein paar Leute mitbringt. Und ist ein beliebter Typ. Wann wurde Australien entdeckt? 2017. Weil Amerika weiß ja jeder grosser Christoph Columbo, aber Australien hat man da gesagt, okay, jetzt haben wir alles entdeckt. Und dann so vier Jahre später so, hallo. Wenn Christoph Kolumbus jetzt kurz mal in ein Museum gehen würde und dann würde er feststellen, Moment mal kurz, das Land, was ich entdeckt habe, heißt Amerika und dann entdeckt er, guckt er weiter südlich und entdeckt Kolumbien, ein kleines unbedeutendes Land.
Der Kontinent heißt Amerika, es gibt Nordamerika, Südamerika und in dem unbedeuteten Teil Südamerika ein unbedeutendes Land heißt so wie das wie ich. Ich stelle dir mal vor, Christopher Columbus fährt an Land, steigt aus und sagt, welches Land habe ich hier gefunden und die U-Einwohner Kolumbien. Mehr so, das ist ein Gag jetzt oder das ist ein Scheiß, verarsch mich jetzt nicht, verarsch mich, ey, ey, ey, verarsch mich nicht jetzt, verarsch mich nicht. Heissen die Indiens, also die Indianer Indiens, weil die dachten, die hätten Indien entdeckt? Ja, ja. Und dann haben die gesagt, scheiß drauf. Und wann haben die gewusst, dass sie nicht Indien entdeckt haben? Es ist ja wirklich nicht so trivial, rauszufinden, dass du das falsche Land gefunden hast. Woher weißt du das denn? Also wie lange hat das gedauert? Der Kartograf. Nee, aber dann hätten sie es erst gar nicht gefunden. Und dann war ein großes Fragezeichen auf der Karte. Es hatte keinen Sinn ergeben. Einfach so, Moment, das fühlt sich nicht richtig an irgendwie. Die haben gesagt Curry, aber irgendwie. Diese Zeit ist für mich eh ein grosses Rätsel. Ich glaube, ich wäre auch, man denkt so, ja, damals hätte man bestimmt auch schon Dinge erfunden und wow, man wäre bestimmt ein spannender Künstler, Erfinder. Nein, was Galileo Galilei da gemacht hat, ist schon abgefahren. Ich wäre ein bescheiter Dienstmarkt gewesen. Der Typ, klar, er hat mit Gläsern, gab es ja schon Glas, keine Ahnung, mit Gläsern, Holz, gab es Holz? Ich weiß es nicht mal. Er hat mit Holz und Gläsern so ein Teleskop gebaut und hat die Monde des Jupiter erforscht. Alter, ich habe ein dafür gemachtes Teleskop in meinem Haus stehen und damit gucke ich in den Himmel und ich kann nicht mal den Mond finden.
Das ist aus einem Kosmoskasten und es ist dafür gemacht, den Himmel zu beobachten.
Ich habe keinen Stimme, wie das funktioniert.
Es gibt eine Anleitung da drin
für Sechsjährige
und ich finde den Mond nicht.
Er kann mit einem Selbstgebauten
selber auf die Idee gekommen,
konnte er den Monde des Jupiter.
Jupiter, finde ich doch nicht. Ja, aber vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht so schwer. Und er war einfach nur der Erste, der es gemacht hat. Das ist wirklich sauschwierig. Er ist schon schwer? Das ist superschwierig. Weil mich denkt mir so, ja klar, Galileo erinnert man sich, aber da gab es doch bestimmt hundert Konkurrenten, die nur Nonsens erzählt haben. Die gesagt haben, nee, nee, nee, die fliegen alle um uns rum. Und nee, nee, die Sonne und die Erde fliegen so gleichzeitig um sich gegenseitig rum. Beide sind in Bewegung und alle so, ja, stimmt, klar. Und dann Generationen, Generationen und so, nee, aber woher soll er es auch wissen? Alle Leute, die du siehst hier, sind alle vergessen in hundert Jahren. Jeder, von dem du denkst, der ist wichtig, weg. Interessiert niemanden mehr. Ich war letztes Mal in einem Musikladen und was ist denn der Prozentsatz an digitalisierter Musik? Doch nur so 0,1 Prozent oder so. Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Was? Oder allein Musik, die gesichert ist, die man safe hat. Ich glaube, da hat man einen Trailer für eine Dokumentation gesehen. Aber da hat man ja auch sehr viel Klassik und sehr viel altertümliche Musik, hat man mittlerweile ja auch schon digitalisiert. Naja, aber jetzt keine Ahnung, so in den 50er, 60er Jahren so Jazz, Blues, da bringen die da 100 Alben raus und dann irgendwie verläuft sich das und die werfen die alle weg und dann ist es einfach verloren.
Es gibt bestimmt wahnsinnig viel verlorene Musik, die einfach niemand auf dem Schirm hat. Und davon, und du hängst ja eh nur auf Spotify rum, da hängst, da ist bestimmt, du hast einen winzigen Bruchteil der gesamten menschlichen Musik überhaupt zur Verfügung, die du haben könntest. In so einem CD-Laden. Was es da für Leute gibt? Ich habe mir dann die Namen angeguckt. Ramones, The Smiths, Joe Black, Leute, die ich von meinem Leben noch nie gehört habe. Da denke ich mir, what, was ist das hier? Und dann Bücher und so. Und dann denke ich mir, es gibt da draußen noch eine ganze Welt, die man nicht kennt. Abba, Abba, was soll das sein? Abba, ja. Was soll das? Willkürliche Worte, was ist das für eine Sprache? Schwedisch. Wobei, ich glaube, tatsächlich, mittlerweile ist man da schon auf einem guten Weg. Ich glaube nicht. Mittlerweile wird da viel mehr digitalisiert. Ich glaube, da ist viel weg. Viel weg. Ich habe einfach Angst, dass bei Spotify mal irgendwann so ein Server ausfällt und dann ist die Lieder einfach weg. Dann kann man die nicht mehr hören. Kann man nichts machen. Du, Mrs. Swift, ganz, ganz blöde Blöde Nummer. Ich bin da auf diese Taste gekommen. Da ist der Kaffee, ist einfach... Könnten Sie Shake It Off vielleicht noch mal einsingen? Ging das? Einfach jetzt spontan am Telefon, weil es ist gerade ganz schlecht. Wir sind am Knopf gekommen. Wir sind am Knopf gekommen. Alles weg. Und die haben noch gesagt, wollen Sie wirklich alles löschen? Und ich so, nein. Und dann habe ich leider auf dem falschen Band gelesen. Können Sie, haben Sie den Beat noch irgendwo rumliegen oder so? Haben Sie noch die MP3 irgendwie so? Aber jetzt den ganzen Frust, den Sie da jetzt spüren. Denken Sie einfach an die Botschaft, die Sie uns mitgegeben haben. Richtig. Shake it off. Das darf doch nicht wahr sein! Nein, das ist Shake it off. Da habe ich Jahre dran gearbeitet. Shake it off. Jetzt ist alles weg. Shake it off, shake it off.
Wie oft ihr das hören müsst, ey.
Wie oft, ey, wie sehr
allein wir Deppen, die keinen Erfolg
haben, schon unter unseren scheiß
Running Gags leiden. Ständig
und mehr aber auch nicht. Überall.
Wie uns das schon nervt.
Wie muss es denn da für wirkliche Weltstars sein?
Wie Shake it off oder sowas.
Wo einfach jeder Depp zu Taylor Swift geht oder Shake It Off irgendwie. Oh, schreibt sie auf Twitter, hey Leute, geht's mir nicht gut. Just Shake It Off. Halt deine Fresse! Auch weil sie auf Drogen ist wahrscheinlich. Ja. Ich glaube, das nervt schon auch bei uns. Auch so Didi Haller vorn. Ich meine, mit dem muss man echt kein Mitleid haben, aber der ist 80 Jahre alt. Und wann hat der eine... Wenn ich noch einmal Palim Palim höre, dann schieße ich mir in die Fresse. Da war er 25 vielleicht oder 30, war wohl 50 Jahre. Und der hört das jeden Tag. Und jedes Mal muss er sich denken, glaubst du allen Ernstes, du kannst bei mir da noch irgendeine Reaktion auslösen, wenn du mir sagst Palim Palim. Ich höre das jeden Tag seit 50 Jahren. Und selbst ich, wenn ich höre, du bist doch so groß, du spielst doch bestimmt Basketball. Selbst dann, das nervt mich ja sogar schon, ich bin 23 Jahre alt und der Typ ist wie alt? 112 Palim Palim. Oder auch mit meinem Nachnamen. Palim Palim! Auch wenn jemand irgendwie einen Gag mit meinem Nachnamen Will macht. Wo ich denke, wie groß schälst du die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein, dass ich diesen Gag noch nie gehört habe. Das ist objektiv noch lustig. Das ist objektiv immer noch lustig. Nein, es ist nicht. Über Will, möchte, Florentin möchte. Ich habe im Alter von sieben oder so stand auf meinem Turnbeutel Florentin Will Turnen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, hey Leute, guckt mal, Florentin will turnen, stimmt gar nicht, hasse turnen. Und alle haben gelacht. Dann dachte ich mir, das reicht jetzt. Jetzt ist es aus. Wirklich? Das ist schon gesagt, okay, das ist nicht die Art von Humor. Obwohl du die Massen begeistert hast, mit Massen meine ich Justin, der gebrochen Deutsch spricht wahrscheinlich. Obwohl du die Massen begeistert hast, hast du gesagt, nee, das ist nicht der Art Humor, mit der ich hier in der 3b berühmt werden will. Ich will mich lieber auszeichnen durch ausgewählten Humor. Hast du den Humor geändert? Ja, ich kann mich tatsächlich noch an eine Situation erinnern, wo ich im Kindesalter, ich glaube in der ersten, zweiten Klasse, einen grossen Lacher geerntet habe. Und zwar gab es ja den grossen Schulklassenraum und dann gab es so die Garderobe direkt im Anschluss, wo man dann immer seinen Beutel aufgehängt hat und seine Jacke und so. Und dann musste ich während des Unterrichts mit einem anderen Kind da reingehen. Und weil ich dumm war, dachte ich, ah, ich bin jetzt in einem anderen Raum, also hört man mich nicht mehr. Aber die Tür war offen zum Klassenraum, jeder hat alles gehört und dann habe ich ganz laut gesungen und das war mein Gag-Niveau damals, bin ich auch noch sehr stolz und dann habe ich gesungen We are the Champignons.
habe ich gesungen, statt We Are The Champions.
Und habe gesungen und habe das so zwei, dreimal gesungen.
Dann bin ich wieder reingekommen und der ganze Klassenzimmer hat gelacht.
Da dachte ich mir, krass.
Und ich wollte den Gag eigentlich nur für die andere Person machen. Und dann, aber Brace kam mir rein und habe gemerkt, oh, alle haben zugehört die ganze Zeit. Aber es kam gut an. We are the Champignons, also für alle Siebenjährigen da draußen, falls ihr morgen in der 1A mal irgendwie einen Lacher ernten wollt, singt einen alten Klassiker und verändert ein Wort drin. Das ist ein Brenner, Ist der absolute Knaller. We are the Champignons. Auf diesem Niveau habe ich auch ein paar Witze gemacht. Bei den Pfadfällen waren wir irgendwann an der See und dann gibt es auch den DLRG, die Deutsche Lebensrettergemeinschaft. Und ich habe gesagt, den lass ruhig gluggern. Wow! Wirklich, die gesamte Stamm-Graltritter von dem Verein Weltenbummler, der Fahrt für den Stamm, der Wölflinge in den Fahrt für den Stamm kamen, hat sich weggeschrien. Wirklich. Wow. Das war wirklich, glaub ich, ein Highlight. Oder auch wenn Krankenwagen kam, immer zu spät, zu spät, zu spät. Kinderhumor ist echt was Feines. Ich glaube, heute ist der weit verbreitetste Berufswunsch unter Kindern, ist YouTuber. Alle wollen YouTuber werden. Und Kinder fangen ja auch total früh schon an. Teilweise machen die auch schon gute Videos, also sei recht professionell. Ich habe dir schon ein paar mal gesagt, du sollst aufhören, die sechs Serie über YouTube anzunehmen. Nein, ich krieg's einfach mal ran. Was erwartest du denn, was da passiert? Aber stell dir vor, die würden auch anfangen, Comedy-Podcasts zu machen. So wirklich im Ganzen, das wird ja wahrscheinlich immer jünger, oder? Also ich meine, du kannst ja einen Grafen zeichnen, jüngster YouTuber, und dann fangen die mit sechs, sieben an. Du machst ja nur iPad an, Kamera, und dann kannst du da so einen Button, das ist die straight hochladen, musst nichts mehr verstehen, und irgendwann kommen die Podcasts von Kindern vor, die wirklich sagen, hallo, hier ist der Kevin und hier ist die Bianca, hey, hier ist der Justin, oh, was mir letztens irgendwie in der Bimmelbahn passiert ist, und dann erzählen die so ihre Kinderanekdoten, wie geil das ist, so ein Einblick, ne, viel Pups und Kaka. Ja, ja. Hast du die Neo-Magazin-Folge für Kinder gesehen? Ja, reingeschaut. Ja, vom Humor der die sehr schwer zu treffen. Ja, schwieriges Publikum, vor allem dann auch hinten raus das Spiel, ein Spiel, was wir auch mal gepitcht hatten, damals beim Neo-Magazin. Ich bin mir sicher, dass ich es gepitcht habe, du bist mir sicher, dass du es gepitcht hast. Jedenfalls ging es darum, dass man laut schreit und das Spiel hat nicht funktioniert, weil die die ganze Zeit geschrien haben.
Ja, aber es war auch sehr lustig.
Das Spiel ging sieben Minuten lang durch und die haben wirklich sieben Minuten lang durchgeschrieben.
Ja, vor allem das Problem ist ja, wenn, also das war ja so ein Pong-Spiel und wenn du laut schreist, geht dein Spieler nach oben und wenn du leise bist, geht er nach unten.
Das Problem ist, jedes Mal, wenn die einen Ball getroffen haben, haben die sich gefreut und geschrien und dadurch ist er oben geblieben und dadurch haben sie einen Punkt kassiert. Und es ist so schön, dass die eigene Freude über den Erfolg zum Misserfolg führt. Zum Misserfolg führt. So direkt ins Gesicht. Wenn du dich zu sein über etwas freust, dann wird es auch oft schnell unsympathisch, wenn du dich dann zu sehr freust. Aber super schweres Publikum, weil es ist natürlich schwer zu treffen, weil bei Kindern ja so klassische Gag-Mechaniken gar nicht funktionieren. Also dieses klassische, oder wie Rainer Kalmund sagen würde, so du hast... Ja, weil die von Franzik, warum würde er das sagen? Ja, du hast ein Set von Erwartungen, mit dem spielst du. Und Kinder haben halt nicht so viele Erwartungen. Da geht's halt dann direkt auf in die Fresse, da geht's halt dann auf direkt, guck mal, der stinkt, puh, und dann so, da brauchst du kein Wissen und dann lachen alle. Aber so diese klassischen Gag-Strukturen funktionieren nicht und deswegen fand ich diese, ich war auch bei der Aufzeichnung dabei, so lustig, weil nichts ist lustiger als ein Gag, der einfach gegen eine Wand prallt. Weil ich finde, wenn ein erwachsenes Publikum nicht lacht, ist es eher unangenehm, wenn ein Gag nicht zündet, aber bei Kindern ist es so, das geht so direkt ins Nichts, das ist so ein Vakuum rein. Und dann ist es wieder lustig, weil so einfach Stille herrscht. Nicht unangenehme Stille, sondern einfach so freudig wartende Stille. Nichts, nichts geschickt. Weil sie ja nicht wissen, dass sie gerade lachen sollen. Genau, ja, das ist ja auch nicht unangenehm. Kindern ist das ja nicht peinlich, wenn ein Gag nicht zündet. Ne, genau, das ist nicht peinlich, weil die, glaube ich, nicht wissen, was für eine Erwartungshaltung gerade an sie gestellt wurde. Sie warten einfach auf den nächsten Gag. Schon lustig. Das ist ja großartig. Ich habe auch immer ein Problem mit Babys und Kindern in der U-Bahn oder in der Bahn, weil man muss sagen, Kinder sind dann auch oft, wollen bespaast werden. Ich hatte dann, ich saß wirklich im Zug von Köln nach Hamburg, saß ich dann jemand, oder Berlin war es glaube ich, wirklich fünf Stunden lang Zugfahrt, saß ich wirklich einem, was war das, fünfjährigen Mädchen gegenüber, an diesem Tischplätzen und es war wirklich einfach unangenehm, weil die sich die ganze Zeit anguckt. Weil sie hat halt so eine gewisse Erwartung an die Welt und die Welt soll sie bespaßen. Die Welt ist für sie da. Und die ist auch gerade in einem Alter, wo man glaube ich, wo die meisten Leute, die gegenüber von ihr sitzen, Bock haben, sie zu bespaßen. Und Grimassen schneiden, und lustige kleine Sachen machen, und sich mitunterhalten. Aber darauf habe ich keine Lust gehabt. Also habe ich mich vor sie gesetzt, meine Kopfhörer aufgesetzt, rausgeguckt, oder Musik gehört, und masturbiert, und dann habe ich halt mal diese wartenden Blicke geerntet die ganze Zeit. Da habe ich irgendwann, da musste ich auch arbeiten am Laptop und sie hat mich jedenfalls angestarrt.
Und das konnte ich nicht mehr ertragen.
Da habe ich irgendwann tatsächlich einfach die Hand vor die Augen genommen.
Und sie hat gewonnen einfach.
Und die Kappe, sie hat natürlich gewonnen.
Und wenn man überlegt, woher diese Blickduelle ja kommen, die kommen ja aus einer Zeit, ist ja bei Hunden auch so,
wenn du ein Blickduell gegen Hunde verlierst, dann sind sie dominant.
Dann sind sie der Alpha-Wolf und du hast verloren.
Und dann gehört das Haus denen.
Das ist mir schon häufig passiert, dass ich ausgesehen Hunde an befreundeten Hunde verloren habe.
Und das war dann genauso.
Dann habe ich irgendwann einfach die Hand vor den Augen genommen und dann versucht zu arbeiten, weil ich es nicht mehr ertragen konnte, dass sie die ganze Zeit Blicke sucht. Unangenehm. Unangenehm, aber man verletzt Blickt wirklich gegen Kinder. Laute Kinder, ab welchem Alter sagt man dem Kind, es soll leise sein und bis zu welchem Alter sagt man den Eltern, es soll leise sein. Weil wenn ein 14-jähriges, also es ist kein Kind mehr, ein 14-jähriges Menschenwesen Scheiße baut, dann sagst du, hey, kannst du bitte leise sein? Aber ein siebenjähriges Kind, da würde man dann, also wenn man überhaupt was sagt, da würde man den Eltern sagen, könnten Sie bitte ihr Kind leise machen? Schwierig. Einen Moment, dann nimmt sie so einen Lautstärke-Regler. Ganz schrecklich, aber da habe ich auch zu wenig Skrupel, als dass ich da mich beschweren würde, da fresse ich mich rein. Das Schlimmste ist ja, wenn du im Ruhebereich sitzt, im Ruhebereich sitzt und dann kommt jemand mit Kindern rein und das ist das Allerschlimmste, weil eigentlich am liebsten würde ich sie einfach darauf hinweisen, pass auf, das hier ist der Ruhebereich, nur dass sie es wissen, das ist der Bereich im Zug, der am leisesten sein sollte. So, mir ist durchaus klar, dass man Kinder nicht immer kontrollieren kann und die auch einfach laut sind und man einfach nichts machen kann und da viele Machtspielchen hin und her bestehen und sowas. Aber dass sie es zumindest wissen, aber es ist, ich bin da nicht skrupellos genug, weil ich meine, Elternsein ist super scheiße, wenn du alleine als alleine Elternteil mit drei Kindern durch die Gegend ziehst, du hast direkt verloren. Und da brauchst du nicht noch was irgendwelche fucking Fremden dann irgendwo auf dich einhacken und dann so denkst du, ja, ich kann genauso wenig machen wie du. Wir müssen halt Tante Ernie besuchen. Ich saß mal irgendwo ... Anders geht's nicht. Da saß ich mal hier auf der Fenloer Straße, das ist diese belebte Straße in Köln-Ehrenfeld. Und dann kam eine Mutter vorbei mit drei Kindern. Den einen hatte sie auf dem Arm, der hat geweint, der andere saß vorne im Kinderwagen, der hat die ganze Zeit La la la la la la la gesungen. Und der andere war schon ein bisschen älter, der ging dahinter und hatte diese, ich weiß nicht wofür sie ursprünglich da sind, aber man kennt sie von der Kirmes, diese, man hat so einen Stock und unten drunter ist ein Rad. Und die sind einfach nur da, um Lärm zu machen. Und man denkt sich die ganze Zeit, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Also lief da diese Frau vorbei, mit einem wirklich händvoll Einkaufshütten in der Hand, vorne ein Kind im Kinderwagen, lalalala, schreiendes Kind auf dem Arm und das Kind dahinter mit diesem Reifen und ich musste laut loslachen, weil das war wirklich ein Zug des Spasses, der an mir vorbeizog, wo ich dachte, das kann nicht sein, das ist die Hölle, das ist die Hölle, die Frau ist in der Hölle. Furchtbar.
Schrecklich. Apropos Tor zur Hölle, wir hatten neulich eine Bekannte getroffen und die hat mir dann davon etwas erzählt. Und ich dachte zunächst, weil die Stimmung war irgendwie gelöst und ich dachte, es kommt jetzt eine lustige Story. Und das Mindset war, es ist eine lustige Story. Und dann hat sie gesagt, es gibt ja diesen, das fand ich wirklich mega lustig,
es gibt ja diesen Job, dass Leute
YouTube-Videos sichten müssen. Ah ja,
da kommt jetzt auch diese Dokumentation raus. Richtig,
genau, darauf wollte ich auch hinaus. Weil diese
Doku, die geht um,
es klingt zunächst wie eine lustige Prämisse,
fand ich. Es ging um
Leute, die, weil wenn Videos
hochgeladen werden, muss YouTube ja irgendwie kontrollieren, ob das den Richtlinien angemessen ist ja agbs entspricht also müssen leute dachte ich sehr viele langweilige videos gucken ja ist also und wir haben ja schon gelernt algorithmus gleich sehr viele inder sehr viele inder sitzen dann da und müssen dann langweilige youtube videos unter anderem das youtube ufo von uns eine, eine Stunde lang geballter Fun aus New York, zwei fette Leute, die Zuckerflashs haben, beim Reden zugucken und hoffentlich warten darauf, bis sie ihren Schwanz rausholen, was dann nicht passiert und deswegen kommt es dann durch. Dann habe ich also gelacht, als sie mir von diesem Job erzählt hat und plötzlich wurde sie total ernst und total blass und hat gesagt, das ist das Schlimmste der Welt. Das ist die absolute Hölle dieser Job. Weil dann kam heraus, dass YouTube diese Videos schon automatisch durchlässt. Weil die haben wohl Algorithmen, die herausfinden, dass da, weiß ich nicht, kein Blut drin ist, keine Geschlechtsteile drin sind und so. Und die bekommen nur die Videos, wo Geschlechtsteile und Blut drin sind, die also der Algorithmus flaggt. Und damit keine falschen Videos geflaggt werden, müssen die sich das angucken. Das muss man sich vorstellen. Das ist eine Halle. Darüber ist die Dokumentation auch eine Halle voller Leute, die vorm PC sitzen und Videos von Beschneidungen angucken, Videos von Kinderpornografie anschauen, Videos von,pfungen sich anschauen. Das ist, glaube ich, das Schlimmste der Welt. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres. Und dann gehen die abends nach Hause und, weiß nicht, was machen die in ihrer Freizeit? Ja, die Doku heißt The Watchers und deshalb jetzt im Kino zu sehen, viel Spaß. Und dieses Gespräch
fing an mit, da gibt es irgendwo Leute, die
YouTube-Büge sich den ganzen Tag schauen mussten.
Das ist einfach richtig lustig.
Da habe ich ein bisschen zu lang gelacht und dann
ging das Gespräch in eine andere Richtung.
Es gibt ja auch diese 10-Stunden-Nyran-Cat
Compilations, einfach
irgendwie so ein Armer Inder muss, die den ganzen Tag
angucken.
Schrecklich. Dürfen die skippen?
Als Augen hat er auch so zwei Nyan-Cats,
die er hat so oft zu lang gesehen.
Und das ist ein, was das hat so oft lang gesehen. Die dürfen nicht skippen. Naja, aber wenn die schon sehen, ah, Kopf ab, dann müssen die nicht den Rest des Videos angucken. Ja, aber Nieren-Cats müssen die trotzdem zehn Stunden zu Ende gucken, weil es könnte ja ab Stunde neun kann ja die Enthauptung beginnen. Alter. Es gibt diesen einen YouTuber, der immer so total bescheuerte Sachen macht, der halt dann, ich zähle bis eine Million und dann ist es halt wie so ein siebzehnstündiges Video, wo der halt bis eine Million zählt halt einfach und das kannst du ja nicht angucken, weil der könnte ja irgendwann keine Ahnung die Hose runterlassen. Du musst einfach angucken. Ich habe das spannendste Video der Welt gesehen auf YouTube. Und ich weiß nicht mehr, den Namen kriege ich nicht mehr hin, aber ich dachte mir wirklich, das kann nicht sein. Ich habe noch nie was Spannendes gesehen und es kann nicht sein, dass das Video das spannendste der Welt ist. Und zwar war das Video, meine Ameisen planen eine Flucht, so hieß es auf Englisch. My aunts are trying to escape oder sowas. Da war einfach ein Typ mit einer Ameisenfarm. Und es klingt unspannend, ich weiß. Und jetzt dachte ich auch bis heute, dass es sehr unspannend ist. Aber dann geht das Video wirklich eine halbe Stunde lang darüber, wie abgefuckt krass die versuchen zu fliehen. Weil die planen dann, durch so ganz perfide Taktiken haben die dann so verschiedene einzelnen mobilen Leute, die sich oben an die Verbindung zum Deckel setzen, so lange und da will ich so patrouillieren und nicht mehr partizipieren, Essen zu besorgen oder irgendwie dem Stamm zu helfen, diesem Ameisenstamm, sondern einfach nur darauf aus sind, herauszufinden, wann endlich eine Fluchtmusik besteht. Es ist so perfide und die Musik dazu, und ich muss das Video mal raussuchen, aber das ist das Spannendste, was ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen habe. Krass. My answer trying to escape. Oder sowas. Muss ich mal raussuchen, aber das finde ich sehr lustig. Hey, Ameisen sind das Krasseste. Ich weiß nicht, warum Leute Tauben füttern, oder Enten, super langweilig. Füttert Ameisen. Ameisen sind cool. Weil vor allem du schmeißt denen irgendwie ein dickes Stück Pommes hin und dann kommt erst eine und zerrt rum, dann kommen zwei und zerrt rum. Irgendwo hast du fünf Leute, die gemeinsam dieses Stück Pommes wegtragen. Wohin, weiss kein Mensch. Und da sind bestimmt noch mehr Pommes. Es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass es deren erste Pommes ist. Und die haben wahrscheinlich auch noch Ketchup im Haufen irgendwo rumliegen. Einfach so, ah, endlich. Ey, absoluter Lieblingsfilm, das große Krabbeln. Stimmt. Superguter Film. Als Hörspiel habe ich jahrelang zum Einschlafen gehört. Störende Szenen. Da habe ich so Flashbacks, wie dieser große Vogel kommt. Da habe ich ganz kurz immer so, er zuckt es in mir. Ja, und dann fällt das ganze Fressen runter. Oh! Nein, das ist dein Flashback.
Ich habe Angst um das Leben der Ameisen, du das Angst um das Essen
der Ameisen. Ja, natürlich, das ist der grosse
Drama-Umschwung des Films.
Dass sie das ganze
Essen verlieren wegen dem Protagonist.
Oh, und diese widerlichen Grashüpfer.
Ja.
Aber guckt da mal jemand drüber, irgendein Biologe,
der sagt, Leute, aber das ist ganz so eine fiese Propaganda gegen Grashüpfer, die sind gar nicht so schlimm. Und es ist auch nicht schlimm, das gehört halt dazu, dass der Vogel Ameisen ist. Das lehrt der Film einem nämlich nicht. Als Kind denkst du, ah, der Arme, wie heissen die ganzen Ameisen halt, wie furchtbar das ist, dass die gefressen werden und wie cool Ameisen sind und wie schlecht alle anderen Tiere sind.
Aber das setzt ja auch ein gewisses Bild in deinen Kopf, auch ein gewisses Weltbild.
Hast du denn ein schlechtes Image von Heuschrecken?
Ja, ich jetzt nicht. Du bist Propaganda-immun oder du bist einfach...
Ich bin Aids und Propaganda-immun.
Heuschrecken-immun. Keine Angst vor Heuschrecken.
Nee, hab ich jetzt nicht. Das stimmt schon.
Du bist ein krasser Typ geworden.
Du bist echt ein krasser Typ geworden.
Warum bin ich krass geworden?
Du hast dich entwickelt.
Bein Tattoo jetzt?
Ja, unter anderem.
Bin ein Gras-Super-Tattoo?
Steht dir gut.
Willst du dir mal so ein temporäres Tattoo holen?
Ne, das ist mir schon zu krass, glaube ich.
Also ich glaube, temporäre Tattoos finde ich noch uncooler als echte Tattoos. Was würdest du dir stechen lassen? Ich habe schon so viel, wenn ich überlege, wie lange ich darüber nachdenke, was ich mir für eine neue Kaffeemaschine kaufe, wenn die alle kaputt gegangen ist, wie lange ich davor sitze und Preise vergleiche und Marken vergleiche, bis ich mich entscheide dazu, so eine doofe Entscheidung zu treffen. Wie lange würde ich vorsetzen, mir einen Tätowierer auszusuchen und was ich mir tätowieren lasse? Ich glaube, das würde zwei Jahre in Anspruch nehmen, glaube ich, bei mir. Und du würdest wahrscheinlich irgendwie so ein Gag-Tattoo machen, so Anführungszeichen und den Mund rum oder irgendwie sowas. Oh. So in der Gegend. Finde ich nie so schlecht. Aber das ist ein erstes Gesicht-Tattoo oder so eine Note auf den Fuss. Das ist eine Fussnote. Denkst du dich, okay, glaubst du wirklich, über diesen Gag lachst du die nächsten 50 Jahre deines Lebens? Glaubst du, der ist so gut, der Gag? Glaubst du, der ist so gut, der Gag? Ich kenne einen Gag, der so gut ist, dass er 50 Jahre überlebt. We are the jumping young. Ja, das würde ich mir auch tätowieren. Über den Rücken? Ey, es gibt einen YouTuber, den ich irgendwann mal gefunden habe. Lars Pausen und ich hatten mal eine YouNow-Phase. Das ist ja diese Streaming-Plattformen, so ein bisschen wie YouTube. Und da sind ja nur Trottel unterwegs. Also kann man echt nicht anders sagen. Das ist ja wirklich das, was man an YouTube kritisiert. Substanzlosigkeit, kein Inhalt ist nochmal hoch 10 auf YouNow. Weil da sind wirklich Leute, die streamen einfach 20 Stunden am Tag. Und da gibt es Leute, die streamen und dann schlafen die und legen sich schlafen, haben die Kamera auf sich und schlafen acht Stunden lang und wachen auf und streamen weiter. Und du kannst denen acht Stunden lang beim Schlafen zuschauen. Es ist absurd. Und da gab es einen, der hat auch immer Wasserpfeife geraucht und so, der hat dann irgendwann erzählt, dass er sich mal Tattoo geholt hat, als Jugendsünde. Und der hat sich halt wirklich, hat sich der Tätowierer halt einfach knallert verschrieben. So, und das ist halt, und vor allem, das ist ja was anderes, wenn du das lustig erzählst, so irgendwie mega scheiße, total dumm, aber der hat das halt wirklich so ernst, so, ja, ist halt schon ein bisschen blöd, dass er sich jetzt verschrieben hat, und, ähm, na ja, gut, ist jetzt halt so so und er wollte sich auf den Arm tätowieren lassen, Heroes Never Die. Und dann tätowiert wurde, Huros Never Die. Und halt wirklich so über den ganzen Arm Huros Never Die. Und wo ich mir denke, wie kann das passieren und wie unglaublich furchtbar das ist. Vor allem schon als zweite Buchstabe.
Und man denkt so.
Und dann steht der Video und denkt so, ah, scheiße.
Niesig H, U, dammit.
Und dann löst du es jetzt auf?
Oder schreibst du noch Rose never done? Genau, du wächst noch mal aus in der Kurse und sagst, okay, pass auf, wir haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Aber er hat sich offensichtlich jetzt so durchgerungen, den Rest noch zu machen.
Ja, und du sagst halt, okay, pass auf, wir haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder wir hören hier auf und du hast Hu auf dem Abstand. Oder wir überlegen uns, welche coole Wörter kann man mit Hu machen, aber da fallen wir nicht. Hund, Hut, Hut. Okay, pass auf, wir machen es so kurz und schmerzlos, wie es, wir machen Hut. Oder was halt Hut auf der... Ist was einzigartiges. Niemand hat Hut. Kaum einer hat Hut. Hut. Auf der Hut. Hut ab. Hut ab. Also bezeichnend. Hut ab. Ja, eigentlich wollte ich ja Heroes Never Die, aber jetzt habe ich mich für Hut ab. Du wolltest doch Hut ab, du wolltest doch Heroes Never Die. Oh Mann. Im letzten Moment unentschieden. Aber sind denn, Frage, sind denn falsch geschriebene Tattoos kostenlos dann? Kriegst du Geld zurück, kriegst du sogar mehr Geld? Also ich glaube, das ist die unangenehmste Geldtransaktion aller Zeiten. Das ist wie wenn du den falsches falsches Bein amputierst oder sowas und denkst dir, ja, mach ich trotzdem 100 Euro. Das stimmt, da hat nämlich jemand, das passt so gut zusammen, falsches Bein amputiert und Tattoo folgt zu einer anderen Story, genau so. Es gibt nämlich jemanden, der hat ein Pfeiltattoo. Und das sah genauso aus wie die Markierungen, wenn etwas amputiert wird. Und dann hat der Chirurg diesen Pfeil gesehen am Bein und hat das falsche Bein amputiert. Das ist doch eine Urban Legend. Wirklich? Ich meine, es kommt statistisch wahrscheinlich vor, dass Leute falsche Sachen amputieren. Das sind ja auch nur Menschen so, da passieren ja Fehler.
Das muss ja auch passiert sein, bis du dem Moment mal gesagt hast,
komm, wir markieren es jetzt,
wir machen uns X drauf. Ja, ja, wie so Förster,
einfach so, die Leute
fällen Bäume links und rechts. Pass auf,
wir machen folgendes, wir sprayen die an
und dann kriegen wir es irgendwie hin.
Aber es gibt solche Leute. Es gibt solche Leute.
Es gibt auch solche Chirurgen.
Es gibt Leute, also ich schau mir, ich bin, YouTube ist auch scheiße so, weil YouTube bestraft dich für deine Fehler. Du hast halt mal so einen schwachen Abend und schaust dann halt irgendwie nur so, keine Ahnung, halt so, weiß nicht, so Fußball-Compilations an oder so, so Sachen, die du halt nie anschaust, so die besten Torwart-Skills. Und YouTube denkt sich, du magst Fußball oder was? Du liebst Torwart-Skills. Du liebst also Fussball. Hier sind 15 Channels, wo du Torwart-Skills angucken kannst. Eigentlich mag ich gar nicht so gern Fussball, aber dann hängt es halt in deinem Kanal drin. So ein Rabbit Hole. Ja, aber so entwickeln sich ja auch Hobbys und Interessen und vielleicht auch so kleine Phasen. Vor allem, YouTube hat keine Hoffnung, dass sich Menschen bessern. YouTube sieht, oh, du bist gerade auf einem schlechten Weg. Und er ist das genau das Gegenteil von einem guten Freund. Er sagt so, ja, weiter auf dem Weg. Ja, weiter. Schlechter Einfluss. Oh, noch Collection, oh, hier noch eine Compilation, noch eine, komm schon, komm schon, komm schon. Er schubst sich den Abgrund noch weiter runter. Schrecklich, und du hast keine Chance auf Recovery, weil du bist dann drin. Ich bin so in einer Prankphase. Oh nein, die hatte jeder doch mal. Naja, aber ich bin jetzt, ich bin der ganze Stadt, das ist voller Pranks. Die sind ja lustig für einen Abend. Und da habe ich auch Videos gesehen von diesem klassischen Basketball, letzte Sekunde, jemand wirft noch quer über das Spielfeld den Ball, wenn der Ball in der Luft ist, dann ... und dann ist er er drin, dann jubeln alle und so. Zählt dann aber nicht mehr, weil es schon Dirt war? Ich glaube, das zählt dann noch, wenn es Dirt in der Luft ist. Wenn Luft Dirt, dann zählt es noch. Wenn es nicht einen Hund geschworfen hat, dann zählt es nicht. Das wurde extra nochmal, weil das ist dann konfus. Und dann denke ich mir auch mal so, naja, geil, aber es gibt halt auch die, die auch in einem anderen Team sind. Du denkst so, wir haben gut gespielt das ganze Spiel lang und alle rennen auf das Spielfeld und jubeln, aber das Verliererteam. Gibt's halt auch. Du seid so ein bisschen in der Startseite voll mit Verliererteams. Loserteams. Eigentlich, also, bist du jemand, der so für den Underdog ist oder der für den Favoriten ist? Underdog. Immer der Underdog. Das sind die cooleren Geschichten. Aber eigentlich ist doch für den Favoriten es viel schlimmer zu verlieren. Oder nicht? Weil der Favorit denkt, er hat gearbeitet, wir kriegen das hin. Aber wir sind ja Autoren, Comedyautoren, wir lieben ja Überraschungen, wir lieben größere Konflikte, gleich größerer, größerer Fun.
Also, der Anderdog gewinnt, ist erstens größere Freude, Favorit verliert, größere Frust, also alles dabei, was man für einen geilen Abend braucht. Ja. Ja.
Es gibt, das war neulich mal eine Presse, auch ganz seltsam, dass wir das nicht besprochen haben, aber Cricket, es gab ja diesen riesen Cricket-Skandal und Australien liebt Cricket und dann gab es einen Cricket-Skandal und hier wurde es eher so auf den Fun- und Unterhaltungsseiten, auf der Witze-Seite war so ein kleiner Artikel über Cricket und da war das halt eine nationalen Schande. Und dann war wirklich, da gab es so einen Nationalheld, nämlich, ich weiß nicht, irgendeinen Trainer, glaube ich, von einem Cricket-Team, der hat dann Bälle manipuliert mit irgendwas. Ach was. Und dann hat sich sogar der Präsident, der Präsident von Australien, König, Inselkönig, der hat sich dann auch dazu geäußert. Der Premierminister von Australien musste sich dann zu dem Cricket-Cricket-Skandal äußern, weil so ein Typ einfach so, weiß nicht, Klepppapier auf den Ball geklebt hat und damit irgendwas beeinflusst hat irgendwie in der Aerodynamik. Und dann gab es ein Interview, wie er dann zurückgetreten ist von seinem Posten als Cricket-Trainer und hat einfach geweint in diesem Interview. Und man will die ganze Zeit, man guckt dieses Video und denkt sich,
Alter, es ist nur Cricket.
Es ist fast scheißegal. Niemand interessiert sich für Cricket.
Ja, es ist ja schon krass,
dass diese Sportarten alle so krasse
Bubbles sind, weißt du, und Cristiano Ronaldo
von vielen Menschen vergöttert
und verehrt wie ein Gott, aber lass dir
mal Wasserball spielen. Und dann denken sie auch
so, keine Ahnung, wer bist du noch mal? So, der ist ein König in einer Welt, aber der letzte Depp in einer ganz anderen Welt. Oder Golf. Golf ist auch so eine ganze Welt. Der Geburts, äh, dieser Deutsche gibt es doch noch, wie heißt der Nummer, Ma? Golf wird sich mir nie erschließen. Vor allem Leute, die zu Golf-Veranstaltungen sich anschauen. Warum flüstern die Kommentatoren? Ja, um das nicht zu stören. Aber die sind doch nicht direkt daneben. Doch, doch, die stehen mit auf dem Feld. Nein, die stehen aber nicht unmittelbar neben dem Menschen. Ich glaube schon. Oh, hier ist Parfiel und jetzt muss Tiger Woods. Das ist der einzige Golfer, den ich kenne. An der Stelle war die Frage, warum flüstern wir eigentlich? Wir sind doch, warum wir nicht sterben wollen. Wir sitzen im Truck, Golf-Truck von Goodyear, die besten Reifen. Und wenn ich überlege, eigentlich müssten wir gar nicht... Ah, er wird sich gestört. Und? Wir müssen leider schmerzen. Okay, sorry, sorry, Tiger. Sorry, sorry, Merkürdige Vorname. Sorry Tiger, also, Tiger, wer nimmt seinen Sohn? Tiger, Tiger, und da kommt der, oh, wobei liegt der viel zu schnell, ich hab schon wieder direkt in die Sonne geschaut. Das wird betont. Ich sehe den Ball gar nicht. Warum ist der Ball weiss? Ich habe jetzt so weisse Flecken vor den Augen. Das brennt.
Wo ist der Ball? Hast du den Ball gesehen?
Ich habe den Ball nicht gesehen.
Aber er lächelt. Wo ist der Ball weiss? Ich habe jetzt so weisse Flecken vor den Augen, das brennt.
Wo ist der Ball, hast du den Ball gesehen? Ich habe den Ball nicht gesehen. Aber er lächelt, ich glaube er lächelt, nein, vielleicht, er wird auch von der Sonne geblendet, er kneift die Augen zu. Ja, ich glaube, ich gehe mal kurz. Und der Ball ist im Teich, der Ball ist im Teich. Was passiert jetzt nochmal? Wir müssen kurz in die Regeln. Und auch Tiger scheint ratlos, setzt sich jetzt in diesen kleinen Speedster und berühmt die Wabe. Das heißt jetzt erstmal eine zwölfminütige Pause für uns nochmal. Für uns heißt das, wir können in die Werbung schalten. Wir können in die lange Werbung schalten. Vor allem, wer wir können auch wieder aussprechen. Wer... Warum... Also angenommen, es gibt ja zwei Orte, das Loch und den Abschlag. Und wenn jemand mich würde fragen, würde, hey, wo würdest du gerne sitzen zum Zuschauen? Ich würde doch nie sagen beim Abschlag. Oder? Ich würde doch sehen, wie der aufdotzt und dann halt reingepattet wird. Aber ist niemand, weil du getroffen werden kannst. Ach, weil zum Golfball. Ja, wenn du... Hör auf, Stefan! Selbst beim Eishockey sagen die Leute Augen aufs Feld. Wenn du getroffen wirst, dann war es das erstmal. Und wenn du vom Golfball getroffen wirst, dann ist das noch schlimmer. Der spielt doch auch viel doller und weiter und höher. Ja, vor allem, es gibt ja 18 Löcher. Bewegt sich das... Warum eigentlich 18? Das ist eine unsexy Zahl. Aber bewegt sich das Publikum auch mit? Müssen denn alle aufstehen? Da sind ja wirklich teilweise tausende Leute bei so einem Tiger Woods. Ja, dann bauen die die Tribünen ab. Dann bauen die den Hot-Dog-Stand abgebaut. So ein Bullshit, so ein Schwachsinns-Sport. Aber beliebt bei reichen Leuten. Und der Hot- Hotdog-Verkäufer hofft, dass er in seinem Loch tatsächlich nicht Paar getroffen wird, sondern darüber halt, über Paar. Ach, jetzt wird das 18. Loch lassen wir heute, Tiger ist so weit vorne. Nein, das ganze Eis. Ich habe heute auf Loch 18 gehauen. Das ganze Eis schmilzt doch. Bullshit, aber ich würde wirklich gerne mal Golf spielen. Ja, ey, wir können mal alle Sportarten durchgehen. Ich würde mal gerne Cricket spielen. Und Polo. Ey, ich würde sagen, bald ist Sommer, bald ist wieder Fit kann auch lustig. Wir starten wieder Fit kann auch lustig. Ey, Fit kann auch lustig 2018. Genau, nach den grossen Erfolgen 2017, 2016 und 2003. Tatsächlich, manchmal schicken wir uns Leute Leute, letztens haben uns eine Höherin ein Bild von ihr geschickt, wie sie gejoggt ist und Leute nehmen Fitkan auch lustig ernst und Leute, wir machen Leute fit. Andere nehmen das ernst. Wir können es auch mal ernst nehmen. Wir testen einfach mal, wir testen Sportarten. Ey, Squash. Wir testen Squash, Golf, Polo, Spoosh, Polo, auf dem Pferd. Polo. Warum gibt es genau eine Sportart nochmal auf dem Pferd? Warum gibt es nicht Tennis auch noch auf dem Pferd? Oder Pferdball? Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Warum gerade Pferde? Es gibt auch Elefanten, glaube ich. In Indien gibt es auch Polo mit Elefanten. Oder ist es ein rassistischer Rute-ic oder sowas? Vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Sehr heftig, heftig in Kategorien, jetzt, Rute. Also, Rute, pass auf, Alter, pass auf, was du da zeichnest, was aus deinem Füllfederhalter da rauskommt. Seid auch ihr vorsichtig, was ihr zeichnet in der kommenden Woche. Richtig. Denn da müssen wir euch allein lassen, aber in einer Woche sind wir wieder da. Und bis dahin, macht's gut. Und jetzt heben wir erstmal für diese Woche ab.
Und wir heben ab, jetzt wird abgehoben.
Jetzt heben wir ab.
Los, los, los, los.
Schnell rein, schnell rein.